you like to set people up too don't you
i do i mean i love love i love people in
love
that's nice like get caught up in the
right
love
like spies love
that's why you and i never agree right
that's it um so i yeah i had set up this
couple a really really good friend of
mine
and i thought it was like the perfect
match made and that night they go out on
a date and i'm like dreaming of their
marriage and so excited and the next
morning he had taped the dinner check to
my front door and said how are we going
to settle this
so
what yes so he was that unhappy with the
date he didn't think it was even you
know everyone's about it being even like
they have to kind of look the same and
be on the same plane and all that so i
guess i don't know if i like this guy
that's not cool i don't want to say he
sounds like a dick yeah yeah
so i should keep trying
no i don't i've never tried to set
anybody up i don't know if i mean
my wife is obsessed with setting people
up and i think no
is she good at it no she's terrible at
it she's awful
you know what i mean people are always
mismatched you know he's a former male
model and a tech billionaire she's a
witch
but you're not gonna get along
uh no she's absolutely awful actually i
also i also find too like
if if i like
a woman enough i don't want to set her
up with my friends because why would i
sick these weirdos on her yeah you've
got i mean well you've got weird friends
yeah they're all broken damaged goods
yeah poor woman
go find someone else it's like the
circus is in town with your pals come
around
uh all right let's talk about uh legends
you get to do you get to do some stunts
on on legends i mean i hope not now yeah
but uh when you're not with child you're
doing something like stunt driving yes
yeah it's not something i'm good at i
always warn at the beginning of
production that i'm not the person to
ask for any kind of stunt driving um
from when i was a little girl even when
i was sledding i remember like my dad
taking me to this big hill in cherry
hill new jersey and there was like a
huge oak tree on the left-hand side and
he put me on the sled and he goes
whatever you do don't veer towards the
oak tree so i get on that sled and i
veered right towards it i headed
straight down i've been obsessed with
hitting this oak tree smack done well
see that was almost his fault because if
you say to someone whatever you do
you know don't hit the oak tree that's
what i'm doing completely my dad's got
to get the oak tree scarred me for life
yeah i blame him i blame him too uh okay
so our we have a clip here from legends
what do we need to know about this clip
um you know what we're agents in the dco
the deep cover-ups of the fbi and martin
odom is played by sean bean who is just
such a talented actor and he's always
causing a problem for me i'm trying to
handle him trying to keep him in line
and he's always off going rogue so it's
a constant kind of fun conflict to watch
let's take a look at this clip from
legends
you saved the operation today
all right it's not how i would have done
it but
[Music]
she kept her composure you preserved
your cover you know we have a chance of
actually stopping this thing
it was
impressive
well
i bet that wasn't easy for you to say
you have no idea
legend
premieres tomorrow night at nine
on tnt congratulations yeah
congratulations we're really happy for
you